[Música]
cuántos de ustedes se han sentido
desconcertados con el inicio de la
cuarentena y con la pandemia que dura
hasta la actualidad la pandemia nos
generó desconcierto porque teníamos
temor de contraer el virus y nos impulsó
a cambiar nuestro estilo de vida de la
noche a la mañana
esta situación nueva nos generó que
teníamos que adaptarnos algunos nos
adaptamos y otros no lograron adaptarse
y yo desde la psicología y desde la
terapia cognitivo-conductual ayudó a las
personas a que vivan mejor y más
satisfechas
la terapia cognitivo-conductual explica
el comportamiento humano con cuatro
componentes el biológico
el emocional el cognitivo y el
conductual
en esta situación de riesgo de vida y de
riesgo al estilo de vida estos
componentes se manifiestan de la
siguiente manera
el componente biológico activa a nuestro
cerebro y nos dice estás en peligro el
componente emocional
expresas emociones como tensión angustia
desconcierto e incertidumbre
desesperación y esto va acompañado de
manifestaciones fisiológicas como
tensión inquietud temblor y hasta puede
paralizarnos
el componente cognitivo no puede
organizar soluciones entonces no
experimentamos depro emociones positivas
el componente conductual se expresa de
dos formas o enfrentamos y organizamos
nuestra vida para adaptarnos a vivir en
pandemia o wii nos seguimos quiere decir
que no hemos aceptado la situación que
no la hemos resuelto y la ansiedad sube
hasta puede paralizarnos
los seres humanos cuando experimentamos
ansiedad estamos muy atentos a lo que
sentimos y podemos sentir inquietud
palpitaciones dolores de cabeza dolor de
espalda y esto es
lo que
se siente con ansiedad
la terapia cognitivo-conductual explica
los componentes de la conducta humana
pero cómo se relacionan entre sí y
ofrece ayuda estrategias para que se
sientan mejor
así es como llega a mari a mi
consultorio ella no podía organizar su
vida en pandemia a su esposo y a ella le
habían reducido el sueldo a 50% y no
sabía cómo organizar su presupuesto para
ella todo esto era nuevo actividades
nuevas de casa ayudar a los chicos para
entrar a sus clases
y asistir a sus reuniones de trabajo
ella se sentía incapaz de adaptarse a
esta situación entonces yo como
terapeuta quería saber cómo es que ella
se sentía incapaz qué es lo que pensaba
cuando se sentía incapaz y que sentía y
esto es lo que ella manifestó ella no
podía dormir sentía cosquillas en el
estómago se sentía muy tensa no podía
pensar su cabecita le decía es algo pero
ella no sabía qué
había temblor
inquietud y entonces ella no podía
levantarse quería seguir durmiendo
sentía mucha dificultad para poder
levantarse y organizar su día
mariah estaba sintiendo ansiedad
los seres humanos podemos sentir
ansiedad de esa manera y eso hace que
nosotros nos concentremos en lo que
sentimos y eso incrementa la ansiedad y
hasta podemos experimentar tristeza
mariah necesitaba ayuda
entonces le planteamos que podíamos
ayudarla a que se sienta más tranquila y
a que se adapte a la nueva situación de
vida
es así que le presentamos la técnica de
la respiración diafragmática le
enseñamos que tenía que tomar el aire
desde su estómago llenar sus pulmones de
aire detener la respiración por 10 a 15
segundos y luego botar el aire
lentamente
que esto lo hiciera tres veces para que
se pudiera sentir más tranquila o cuando
hacían las actividades de casa y ella se
daba cuenta que su cuerpo estaba tenso
como seguía enfocada en lo que sentía
le planteamos la estrategia de la
redirección de la atención para ayudarle
a que su atención no estuviera en ella
misma sino en los sonidos que estaban en
su ambiente así le propusimos que cuando
se duchara escuchará el agua de la ducha
que cae en su cuerpo que cuando lavará
la vajilla escuchar el agua que salía
del caño y cómo chocaba y hacía ruido
con los platos que cuando hicieran sus
actividades de casa ella escuchará los
ruidos de los carros que pasaban frente
a su casa
y ya está el cantar de los pajaritos
maría comenzó a valorar estos sonidos
antes pasaban desapercibidos pero ahora
los disfrutaba y ya está el de agradable
mariah
tenía que hacer sus actividades de casa
y a veces no le provocaba a levantarse
entonces le enseñamos la técnica de
solución de problemas es decir que nos
contara qué es lo que sigue qué es lo
que hacía y en el día desde que se
levantaba hasta que se acostaba entonces
ella nos dijo que se levantaba preparar
el desayuno ayudaba a los chicos a
entrar a sus clases así a las
actividades de casa asistía a las
reuniones de trabajo preparaba el
almuerzo con ayuda al esposo volvía a
asistir a las reuniones de trabajo
ayudaba a los chicos con las tareas que
tenían que hacer preparar la comienza a
acostar a la hora que llamaba toda su
día maría se da cuenta que ella era útil
eficiente y capaz porque se estaba
adaptando a este nuevo estilo de vida
como todavía le daba un poco de
para organización
para levantarse le enseñé la técnica del
autocontrol los seres humanos tenemos
que aprender a valorar las consecuencias
de nuestro comportamiento entonces ella
se dio cuenta que hacía las cosas y
valoro positivamente las consecuencias
de lo que hacía si se quedaba paralizada
valoraba negativamente
poco tiempo después nos dijo que ella se
sentía un poco asfixiada de su vida
entonces le plantee la técnica de
soporte social le plantee que ayudara
llamar a su amiga y le contara cómo era
su día y que la amiga también le contara
cómo era su día maría
escucho a la amiga y se dio cuenta que
no era la única que tenía este estilo de
vida pero se sintió escuchada
comprendida querida y valorada después
de seis meses de terapia maría superior
y organizó su vida y se adaptó a la
pandemia mariah aprendió
a tomar decisiones
al relajarse a darse cuenta de sus
pensamientos de emociones y
comportamientos aprendió habilidades que
no tenían mariah aprendió de la pandemia
todos los seres humanos
podemos tener
momentos difíciles
y tenemos dos opciones
no hacemos nada y nos paralizamos
aprovechamos esta situación para
tener la oportunidad de descubrir de lo
que somos capaces